[Música]
en Estados Unidos El juez de la suprema
corte de Samuel alito congeló la medida
de un juez conservador que prohibía el
uso de mifepristona en varios estados
del país sobre este tema ahora se espera
que se dé un pronunciamiento del
tribunal mientras el gobierno de joeyden
Busca vías para defender en la
disponibilidad del medicamento abortivo
frente a las crecientes prohibiciones y
restricciones del aborto que han sido
promulgadas por los estados liderados
por republicanos Desde que la Corte
Suprema anuló en junio del 2022 la
histórica decisión de rubyway Cuál es el
panorama de este y de otros casos
visibles en el país que limitan los
derechos sexuales y reproductivos pues
vamos a comentar este tema con Elida
caballero que Cabrera quien es directora
senior de campañas y programas de
incidencia en wimens y Quality Center es
abogada además Gracias y bienvenida
Elida mire quiero comenzar preguntándole
después de que un juez de republicano
prohibiera el uso de mifeprissona y que
un demócrata contradijera la orden pues
esta es una pelea de que ya llegó hasta
la Corte Suprema que es lo que puede
pasar ahí Porque además digamos esta
congelación del litigio finaliza a la
medianoche de hoy
sí es una situación muy preocupante lo
que estamos viendo Es una restricción
total de todos nuestros derechos y del
acceso a nuestros derechos reproductivos
y a los servicios de salud y Hablemos
claro la pistones segura y eficacia ha
sido utilizado por los últimos 20 años
por más de cinco millones de personas
alrededor del mundo y bajo la aprobación
de la fd los ataques contra este
medicamento solamente tienen una
motivación estrictamente política y son
instigados y financiados por personas
extremistas y antiabortistas que lo que
quieren es lograr un control sobre
nuestros cuerpos eso se ha convertido
casi en una campaña de intimidación
contra las mujeres hay que decirlo como
Es sobre nuestro derecho a tener una
sexualidad informada una sexualidad
consensuada además de maternidades
deseadas y planeadas porque la
mifepristona es apenas un episodio más
no después de la anulación de Robbie
wade hemos visto como Estados Unidos
pasó de ser un país progresista en
términos de los derechos sexuales y
reproductivos a restringir por ejemplo
las posibilidades de aborto casi
completamente en varios de los estados
luego está ron de santis que es un
fuerte precandidato digamos para las
elecciones que promueve que no se hable
de menstruación en los Colegios
justamente en la edad en que las niñas
más necesitan conocimiento sobre el tema
que no se hable acerca de diversidad
sexual etcétera etcétera entonces pues
como esto estaba afectando nuestros
derechos de existir en el mundo de
existir en un país como Estados Unidos
Mira nuevamente preocupante y afecta
directamente no solo a las mujeres y a
las niñas y a las personas con
capacidades estar por todas las
restricciones que están teniendo para
acceder a los servicios de aborto a los
servicios de salud Esto está afectando
nuestra intimidad nuestra privacidad
nuestro derecho a acceder a servicios de
salud a educación sexual que claramente
es comprobada que niños y niñas
adolescentes personas que tienen una
educación sexual completa laica
basada en ciencia pueden proteger su
niñez y su juventud y con todas estas
restricciones los que estamos es creando
una gran crisis sobre todas las cosas
que pueden afectar a al futuro de todos
de todas las personas no solo en Estados
Unidos sino también en el mundo las
prohibiciones del aborto y todas estas
prohibiciones que Honestamente son
totalmente ridículas lo que hacen es
crear una crisis de salud pública una
crisis de Derechos Humanos
crisis económica y en América Latina
hemos visto muchas veces muchas veces
las nefastas consecuencias que estas
prohibiciones tienen y cuáles son los
Qué pasa luego de que las personas no
tienen acceso a servicios de salud a
servicios de Educación aumenta la
pobreza disminuye la capacidad de esas
personas de desarrollar su personalidad
en la totalidad y de ser ciudadanos de
primera clase y eso es lo que estamos
viendo como un futuro muy muy tenebroso
en Estados Unidos y hemos Hemos de ser
muy claros Elida en que al final estas
medidas no frenan las decisiones de
aborto o cualquier otra decisión sexual
y reproductiva de una mujer lo que hace
es aumentar los niveles de riesgo y
además al evitar que por ejemplo la
mifepristone en el caso de Estados
Unidos llegue a algunas partes del país
pues esto simplemente va a limitar las
maneras seguras que tienen las mujeres
del acceso por ejemplo la interrupción
del embarazo ahora lo que sí le tengo
que preguntar es cómo estas políticas
regresivas de las cuales Florida es un
gran ejemplo eh Como no digas gay o no
hablar de la menstruación
mueven aún así tantos votantes se han
vuelto tan populares en el país esto Más
allá del activismo más allá de nuestra
propia opinión usted porque cree que han
sido también acogidas estas medidas por
algunos sectores de la población
Mira yo he estado leyendo varias
encuestas especialmente en Florida y he
visto que el 61% de las personas en
Florida no están de acuerdo con la
prohibición de seis semanas que que se
está trabajando la mayoría de las
personas en Florida no está de acuerdo a
la prohibición y a la restricción de sus
libertades y derechos sobre todo la
privacidad lo que pasa es que creo que
hay una un auge grande de desinformación
hay un auge grande de
poner a todas las cosas en un extremo
las personas no están conversando y creo
que es importante poder conversar con
las personas poder escuchar cuáles son
sus puntos de vista cuáles son sus
miedos sobre todo en Casos de cosas que
no conocen yo en el trabajo que hacemos
diariamente hemos visto cómo conversar
Cómo escuchar a las personas y poder
entender dónde están De dónde viene y
cómo poder extenderles una mano amiga
informativa ha ayudado a cambiar
Muchísimas las perspectivas las personas
pero honestamente y lo vimos en las
últimas elecciones
estas previsiones no son populares en
todos los Estados Unidos ni siquiera en
estados que hemos catalogado como
conservador como conservadores bueno
todas las iniciativas de balox que hubo
en las elecciones anteriores perdieron y
todas eran pidiendo una prohibición de
algún tipo o en algún nivel sobre el
derecho al acceso al aborto Entonces
estamos viendo que estas restricciones
no son populares y que siempre y
sencillamente están siguiendo utilizadas
en una guerra política que se va
afianzar más Mientras más nos acercamos
a las elecciones del 2024 esto
finalmente fue lo que detuvo la gran
llamada marea Roja en las elecciones de
medio término pero contra las votaciones
pues está la situación que vivimos en la
corte de Suprema que es de mayoría
conservadora y que llevó a la caída de
Robbie White Así que mi última pregunta
y muy rápidamente porque nos quedamos
sin tiempo es cuál es su previsión qué
es lo que va a pasar en la Corte Suprema
con la mifepristona Porque no sería
extraño que la prohibición aumentara
después de lo visto con el derecho al
aborto
Mira yo soy una persona que lo en el
trabajo que hacemos nunca perdemos La fe
es lo único que tenemos y ni la
esperanza y yo estoy muy esperanzada de
que con la ayuda de los legisladores y
los activistas de Estados Unidos eh esta
previsión no no puede hacer No no sea
aprobada va a ser un gran golpe y no
solo para para el acceso al aborto sino
también para el acceso a muchos
medicamentos que la fda ya ha aprobado y
que tienen consenso a nivel
internacional lo cual le quitaría mucha
legitimación al trabajo que hace una
agencia como el epidemia a nivel mundial
Pues sorprendentemente mientras que
Estados Unidos va en retroceso América
Latina Parece que va hacia el
progresismo en Argentina hace pocos días
fue aprobado el uso de este medicamento
para la interrupción del embarazo
gracias a usted Elida caballero Cabrera
directora senior de campañas y programas
de incidencia en wimens Quality Center
que tenga un feliz día
Gracias igualmente a nuestros
televidentes siguen en France 24 ya
volvemos con más
[Música]